ça c'est un PC qui a absolument
incroyable c'est le Lenovo yoga book
9000 pourquoi parce que vous avez deux
écrans qu'on peut utiliser comme ça en
mode paysage qu'on peut utiliser comme
ça à la verticale donc si vous voulez
vous regarder un petit d'un côté un
petit Tik Tok et de l'autre côté un
petit snapchat et ma facile on peut le
faire et si vous voulez venir bosser
aussi comme ça vous pouvez le faire là
où est le spectacle et ce qui est
vachement intéressant c'est que vous
avez un accessoire sur lequel vous venez
le poser permet de le maintenir et dire
bosser très très facilement ça c'est
cool en plus de ça vous avez un petit
stylé si on veut derrière et ce qui va
m'intéresser ici c'est que lorsque vous
venez ouvrir une fenêtre par exemple ici
vous prenez 5 doigts et vous venez de
glisser sur le bas ça vous l'ouvre en
grand ça c'est vachement cool autre
fonctionnalité qui est assez marrante
vous prenez 8 doigts et vous allez avoir
votre clavier qui apparaît là le clavier
et si vous voulez descendre le clavier
pour mettre des widgets vous prenez vos
8 doigts et vous descendez juste en bas
en plus de ça votre petit clavier vous
venez le poser là et vous allez
retrouver ici un petit trackpad c'est
pratique et vous pouvez également venir
le poser sur le bas si vous le souhaitez
pour garder une partie en mettant des
widgets bref c'est un PC que je trouve
très marrant
2499 €, il va arriver au printemps
prochain en France je vous rappelle la
référence c'est le yoga book 9 i je
trouve très cool dites-moi d'ailleurs
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas dans
les commentaires